[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thanks for listening
today thanks for uh tuning in every
Tuesday or whenever you listen to your
uh podcasts how many podcasts can you
listen to
at once well not at once but uh but look
thanks for listening to mine
um if you enjoy this interview with Ryan
Kelly
um I urge you to write a review
follow us and subscribe at inside you
podcast on Instagram and Facebook at
insideipod on the Twitter we really
appreciate it and uh
we've got tons of merch on the inside of
you online store uh new sorority boy
statues uh there's only three uh left
already
um zip UPS inside of you zip UPS uh
lexmiths from Smallville scripts tons of
stuff go to the inside of you online
store get your merch now
um and also join patreon if you want to
support the podcast like many do at the
end of this podcast we read all the top
tier names that are patrons and they get
lots of uh perks like a zoom with me
here and there and uh boxes and notes
and uh YouTubes and a bunch of stuff so
go to patreon.com inside to support the
podcast and without you we couldn't do
it and I appreciate it I'll send you a
message back I will I always do
I'm also on the Cameo and my band
sunspin uh we uh we just played a show
and it was awesome and thanks for coming
out you can go to sunspin.com for Merch
to book the band zooms all that stuff so
it's a lot of fun and also listen to uh
talkfill my other podcast with Tom
Welling and Ryan yeah yeah and inside of
you live podcast yes live podcast in Los
Angeles Regent Theater 7 P.M actually
earlier if you get a meet and greet with
me and Zach Levi yes Zach Levi he's the
guest and live podcast at the region
theater 7 P.M October 11th Wednesday
Ryan will be there I will of course be
there it's gonna be so much fun I'm
nervous I'm excited uh I hope you come
and join and support the podcast like
you always do and if you can get out to
LA it's gonna be a freaking show man
right you uh you doing all right yeah
I'm doing all right yeah maybe I should
interview you one day
sure
what would that be like
I'm gonna get inside of me I don't know
you gotta get along with your family
your you know you seem like you're
mentally sound you know you've got I got
Darkness do you man hey man I can share
my darkness hey man I can get dark
you wanna get dark guys Derek if you
want to get dark oh yeah we can get dark
I'll go jit dark oh yeah
Falcon race we'll go darker than that
I'll go for it we'll go winter in
Alberta we'll get so dark we'll [__]
get up go for a rep after go for a rip
you always are going for a rip
make sure I got enough loonies and
toonies and we're in my two can we go
for a rip it's cold back there in
Saskatchewan
this is what would happen
all right listen we got a great podcast
for you uh Ryan Kelly
um he said a terrific career
um and it started really on Smallville
and he was on the show a few times and
we talk about that and we talk about
life and he opens up and um he's got a
big following such a sweet guy it was so
nice having him here I think you're
really gonna enjoy this one so let's get
inside of Ryan Kelly it's my point of
view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of the live studio
audience
hey folks wanted to highlight something
important before today's episode in case
you weren't aware of myself and many of
the guests are on strike alongside sag
after nwga today's episode and any we
air before the strike ends were recorded
before it began so this is just a heads
up in relation to some for the topics we
may discuss if you want more info on the
strike visit
sagafterstrike.org now let's get into it
[Music]
it's it's crazy looking at you because
last time I saw you how old were you
when you did Smallville
everything I'm gonna say I'm always off
a little bit my mom would be like Ryan
that's not even true uh so let's say I
think I was 16 the first time the first
season 16. I'm sure you were that old
and it was 15. I mean also I I looked
like
you looked young you're like me a late
bloomer yes so that's another thing that
was probably throwing you too man I mean
I just remember and I remember thinking
I'm not just saying this but I I think I
told you I don't know if you even
remember but I was I remember it's just
saying you're really good you're gonna
be you're gonna you're gonna work
I remember telling your mom I was like
this kid's good you're well behaved on
set I don't know if she beat you yes I
don't know what what happened but uh it
was just like you know you watch those
episodes those were the best the two
great episodes that you were in
it was heartbreaking yeah right Ryan
Ryan's oh no I've seen it yeah yes yeah
yeah because he's had to watch them
because he does talk Ville as well with
Welling and um what do you what do you
remember just like going back like what
do you remember I mean 15 you're not
that young no so you probably remember
a bit
um I remember I mean again like I said
my memory is terrible so
um it's all those droids man with all
your bulk right uh it's dropped you know
living in Hollywood drugs being dropped
in your head
um but uh what I what I do remember is
Smallville was the first like it changed
my life in the sense of that was I had
been acting when I was younger
um just kind of something my parents
made me do and I enjoyed it don't get me
wrong but it was definitely like not
force but like if I made an obligation
or something mom was like well no you
have to do this right you have to go to
this audition you said you would
um and I took to it I have a bunch of
siblings they didn't like it as much I
kind of loved it and I loved being out
of school I loved yeah acting as much as
I did Sports and Smallville was the
first time that I saw adults
doing it for a living like it clicked in
my head I was like wait yeah I remember
you guys um especially the second season
you guys were going through like talking
to each other about contract
negotiations I remember you remember
that a little bit yeah and I remember
thinking like wow that'd be so cool one
day if I could do that
um but the first one for sure I was like
wait you guys do this for a living like
you don't do anything like you didn't
this is what you do you know and you
guys like yeah so that was the first
time I clicked my head and then that
it's a good thing and a bad thing my mom
probably wishes that never happened
because that was when I made in my head
I was like oh I'm gonna lie to my
parents and tell them I'm applying for
college and not apply to college and
then I'm gonna do this for the rest of
my life that's what you thought at that
age right when you're on set that was
somehow it clicked in dude that was the
first for sure Smallville was like where
I was like oh I I want to do this too
well how do I my parents are gonna make
me go to college how do I I'll just lie
to them and then you know did you did
you like doing it did you like acting I
loved it you loved it I loved I loved
being on set like that part was still to
this day is my favorite thing ever you
love me you would love the process I yes
of making the art itself you know as you
get older the audition part is
yeah here and there you know I mean it's
it's it's the name of the game getting
back to you know like right now I'm not
currently working on anything so it's
getting back to the Grind the grind
putting yourself on tape not going in
anymore right well that part's at first
was kind of tough you know like I do
like the in-person gratification of like
seeing some human respond to your work
however living in Los Angeles now that
I've kind of gotten over that I'm like
dude I do actually not like sitting in
traffic for an hour an hour and a half
like if you have an audition down in
Raleigh studios in Santa Monica I live
in the valley you know right it's an
hour and a half coming back on a Friday
but now you could just like stick your
lines wherever and you don't have to
memorize them when you go to audition
right yeah that's all right look you
know that's how I look at it Ryan
they're right here right here has an
island it doesn't look like I'm looking
at my lines all right we're good roll I
definitely do like certain ports where
like I'll put like uh Post-its yeah of
like a line like or a word I can't
remember and I'll glance at him like oh
yeah yeah now you said your parents
didn't want you to get into this or they
did they did but I don't they wanted me
to I mean for sure like every parent
wanted me to go to college and then and
then if this was something I wanted to
pursue they
they would like me to have like a backup
plan or a degree to fall back on right
yeah but you were like something I I
read is it true about like your
neighbors were going for an audition for
to meet an agent so you're like let's do
that and all of the your siblings you
all went yeah we did like a like a one
of those showcase types who decided to
do that whose idea was that I'm assuming
my mom you know like so I've so the
story is I have 14 siblings right whoa
whoa I didn't know that yeah you have 14
siblings are they all from the same the
youngest nine are adopted from all over
the world
um wow yeah so it was a way to I think
let me like get a head start on paying
off College because there's no way my
parents were gonna pay for 15 kids hold
on hold on
I mean
it's I I hate having in my calendar
going I gotta send my brother something
oh I got to send my uh you know I gotta
call my sister you gotta call 15 people
I mean if you were to talk to my
siblings I'm the worst 13. no 14.
I don't call it I mean I'm the worst I
the only I know my birthday and I know
my older brother's birthday because he's
one day after me the rest of that I get
updates from my sisters like really you
don't know anybody's birthday no no I
don't know you know your mom's I bet
nope you don't know your dad's nope I
mean they're gonna listen to this and
they probably they know this they know I
don't I'm the worst at that stuff I'm so
bad at that are you bad at remembering
or memorizing
um I'm no so because of acting I think
I'm really good at memorizing things for
a short period of time and then gone you
know like if you made me learn a script
I could learn that real quick but then
if you asked me three weeks from now I
wouldn't have a clue I'd be like what
yeah I understand you know like it's
just been trained in my head to like
learn things like I always did good on
tests because I would cram study for
them and then you know if there was ever
like a recap or oh I was feeling that
because I was like wait what so you do
well in school uh I did when I was
younger right so five years old you guys
all go how many do you go to this
audition I don't that's a good question
I need to actually a handful of us a
handful of you yeah and they so you did
a showcase something yeah like you know
when I was like looking for
uh
young talents you know there's a bunch
of names I can't even remember but you
know how many did they choose
uh how many did they
that's another you know what these are
great questions I I if I if I start just
answering them I'm gonna be like
it started you yeah yeah that's what
started off yeah and then also like I
was definitely younger and my older
siblings were the same sort of thing
looked younger mature my parents you
know my mom ruled with an iron fist so
like you know we we listened to her like
my mom's a great mom like I we like you
would see kids on set crying or like
being disobedient running around that
was never us we would listen if my mom
said like hey you're gonna act like this
be mature don't embarrass us we did that
why did you listen to her uh cause my
mom I don't know it's just the way my
mom was she was she tough tough love
yes but no I mean like where's she a
spanker I definitely got spanked we
didn't get beaten but I got stanked yeah
I got spanked yeah I don't think there's
anything wrong with that I think this
whole world now it's like you know
I want to spank my kids for sure yeah
Ryan
uh no I didn't I no I was definitely
afraid of like breaking the rules so I
never did yeah I mean would you have
gotten spanked no uh did I get no no all
I could say is I'm not talking about
beating your kids like you're saying I'm
just saying like a little smack on the
ass saying hey don't I've told you three
times yeah you know wake up my dad in
the mall sometimes I'd be like and like
you know stop that stop that and then
you grab my arm yeah I know I just
honestly I was more scared of my mom's
look but you know that look like
I was scared of my dad's voice yeah I'm
not gonna tell you again you understand
I think that's where I channeled some of
the Lex Luthor stuff nice I did people
said where do you where does he where do
you get that you're kind of a goofy guy
I'm like it's easy just Channel my dad
yeah you know and I I hear
you know even a lot of people do that
um I don't know if Farley if I heard
this or maybe it's wrong but like Chris
Farley would uh you know he like his
Matt Foley there's a essence of his
father and they're like listen to me for
God you know what I mean yeah there was
like that Essence I mean Napoleon
Dynamite John that was just like him and
his brothers they were always like gosh
you're stupid what are you doing yeah
you know you get sort of characteristics
from your friends and family for sure
yeah or experiences well where did you
get that I noticed like even when you
did small but we'll get in Teen Wolf and
all the stuff in the movie and you've
done tons that think you work with
Sigourney Weaver you've worked with a
lot of great people Clint Eastwood right
yeah I can't I mean I can't
that's crazy but what we're gonna say
that's a funny story I mean most of the
stuff I did with him got cut anyway so
that's funny I'm about to do a movie
coming on a lot of my stuff how do you
deal with that by the way how do you
deal with getting cut out or failure uh
well the key to something for for me
like unless I've seen it or I know like
I always downplay everything you know
like I've had friends who make a huge
deal about something especially if
they're newer you know like if they
haven't worked as much and then they get
something and they're super excited
about it and then it's like their
friends and family or you go to this
Premiere and then you don't find out
it's cut till it comes and then you look
from in my opinion you know it's it's an
ego you're like why why did that so I
just never play up anything to where I'm
just like I don't know I mean you know
we'll see yeah I do the same thing and
then when I'm cut I'm like yeah I don't
you know I did more but I don't really
know what happened I think that is a
um
classless act on the behalf of directors
or producers not to call the actor who
had a decent look if you had three lines
and they're not in the movie you don't
have to call this person no mine was
definitely small it was it was a handful
of scenes and and
no it wasn't like yes I understand what
you're saying no they didn't they didn't
owe me a call it was such a massive
movie and and what I had and what they
it was a it was a really cool thing
which is why I did it but then what most
of the cool stuff that I did didn't make
it Rowdy Roddy Piper I did this movie
that was not good and he was uh you know
he had a scene in the movie and he came
to the premiere with his kids and he oh
no one told him he wasn't in the movie
that's messed up and I was like and
afterwards like he goes hey man you're
funny and I go hey I can't believe your
stuff wasn't in there he's like yeah bud
he was so cool he taught me the sleeper
hold yeah I I said hey look does the
sleeper hold really work rowdy rowdy
Piper
he looked at me and goes come here I'm
going to show you some
anyway you just want to grab it right
here and grab your arm around the neck
the other arm goes this way I don't need
a pull here or something and I just was
I was out and he caught me yeah and he
goes now you're gonna do it to me oh I
can't I can't hold you up he goes no
you'll be all right just make sure I
don't fall hit the ground anybody could
do the sleeper hold
did you make him pass out and I made him
pass out because he showed me how to do
and he goes like this and like whoa
yeah see there
and he was it was it was trippy but yeah
that's that's a lousy thing to do isn't
that is not tell someone with such a
name especially yeah and especially if
you're gonna bring your family like oh
fail
inside of you is brought to you by neuro
hacker stay here folks because this
stuff works hear me out I love taking
this stuff qualia mind from neuro hacker
okay
I feel sharper taking this every five
days a week I take this
I take one pill
and I feel sharper I have energy I feel
like I could combine sentences
I could create long sentences
um
from help with my daily mental
performance and help supporting my
long-term brain health neuro hackers
call your mind is indispensable to me uh
it's so cool to take a product where you
don't have to wonder if it's working
because I noticed a difference
immediately unlike a lot of products in
fact I just got this other product for
something else and they're like expect
three to six months I'm like well
Anything could happen in three to six
months I could be feeling better because
I just feel better
but uh this stuff in just days I noticed
my focus my mood
um my willpower to get things done get
her done
our sponsor neuro hacker combines 28 of
some of the most research-backed
nootropic ingredients on earth into an
ultimate brain fuel formula qualia mind
and it's been changing people's lives
for years now and I'm here to tell you
it works the formula is non-GMO vegan
gluten free and the ingredients are
meant to complement one another
factoring in each ingredient's effect on
supporting mental Clarity yeah Ryan it's
also backed by a hundred day money
guarantee money back guarantee I mean
whenever they have a money back
guarantee you know they know that their
product is good you have almost three
months to try neuro hackers call your
mind no Financial Risk and decide for
yourself and then you can say Rosenbaum
he did it you're right see what one of
the best brain fuel formulas on Earth
can do for your mindset go to
neurohacker.com
ilu for 100 off and as a listener of
inside of you use code IOU at checkout
for an extra 15 off your first purchase
that's neuro hacker dot com slash IOU to
try call your mind with code IOU to
experience life-changing mental
performance these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
so your mom was sort of that look you
know she was a disciplinarian but you
guys listened you listen you respectful
but with 13 kids it had to get kind of
Rowdy no I mean people think like you
know like Cheaper by the Dozen you know
I was just Mayhem no it was never my
house my parents uh my mom I don't know
just I think like in life like if you
look people that you meet that have
issues or bad people you know it all
stems from parenting so if you just are
good parents more often than not your
kids are going to be good but just yeah
but how about you have 13 kids how do
you pay attention to all 13 and help
them with their studies I mean I can't
all right your algebra all right next
one there's science don't know anything
about it Kelsey Move Along John here we
go for sure I mean I'm sure there's some
of that I mean that's stuff that I think
about now like you know I'm in my later
30s so I can't imagine what my parents
had to go through but you just
we kind of just did it ourselves and if
we had questions they would help us but
sometimes sometimes I'm sure they
couldn't or weren't as my dad was pretty
good at math but if he wasn't around you
know like my mom's like me we're not
good at math so get a tutor get it
figure it out yeah go to the teacher ask
for help you know you know figure this
out yourself yeah I mean that makes
sense it's just it's just yeah it's got
to be tough like with all those kids it
just it just I I think about it and it's
just like I think you know how I didn't
get any attention growing up and I'm
like I can't imagine what they're on top
of not I mean the best thing about
having so many kids is my mom had
built-in babysitters so also like if I
wasn't getting affection from my parents
I was getting it for myself you know I
was always around my siblings always
babysitter friend no we never had babies
babysitters are my siblings and
sometimes that's good and sometimes it
was bad yeah you know like I had a one
of my sisters was was a tough babysitter
really I mean I was a brat so I you know
she was tough no I just get sent to bed
immediately and you'd listen I had to or
she called my mom and then she's right
and I'm wrong you know did you did you
ever deal with any like you know growing
up and like getting into the acting
world did you ever deal with any like
anxiety and your nerves or are you just
a confident kid because of your you know
product of your own environment being
you know I mean I'm good parents I have
nerves all I mean for everything you get
you have nerves going in you know you
you want to be perfect or you want to
you know I know you can't but you know
you've put in all this work especially
on certain auditions like that's the
thing you try not to care I mean that's
something I've learned is to not care
about auditions I mean I obviously I
care about them but to the the second
you walk out you know that thing of just
like forget about it if it's meant to be
putting their sides away and you know
that's easier said than done there's
definitely some auditions where you're
like come on I really you know like you
can't not
um so yeah I mean there's always nervous
there's always I get nervous for every
audition I go on even just like
but it's nerves of excitement more often
than not because I have put in the work
and I'm ready for the audition the the
nerves that would kill me is if like you
just gave like I hate cold reads so like
that terrifies me or used to terrify me
when I was younger you mean just reading
off this crap you haven't learned them
just read this just like or like you
know like sometimes like what my
nightmare is going in on audition doing
really good on a on a like a like the
character you're auditioning for and
then being like you know what you're
fantastic but you're not right for this
role here's this one and then even
though they know I always think of my
head I'm like the casting director knows
and hopefully they relay that to
whoever's watching but I'm competing now
against kids who've had a week to to
memorize this stuff and I'm hoping they
convey that but maybe not and then when
someone that's not your fault I know I
know about you I know you know like
someone's watching them
yeah he's just reading it no that gives
me crazy I hope I don't know
why is this kind of reading off the
scripture you say that but I don't it's
the same thing when you send an audition
tape like are they actually watching
this I don't know
well Clint Eastwood he casts off I hope
he casts off tape he casts me off tape
all right did you audition for Clint or
did you cast off tape uh no it was for
uh casting director and I I actually
auditioned for a different role and then
they're like the same sort of thing
where they're like dude you're fantastic
you're not we don't think you're right
for this but hey there's this smaller
role but it's actually really powerful
we're moving uh letter Z regima right so
there there's this role that's like
super cool and like it's gonna paint
this terrible thing about war and we
think you could crush it you're a marine
yeah and and originally I was gonna have
this like insane dying death scene like
you know again it's someone looking like
the whole point was just showing how
awful it is and like you know some Kid
Fresh Off The Boat like barely out of
high school you know fighting for his
life and it's this really cool dying
scene and uh
I went out there first off it was the
craziest experience I went out in
Barstow and tried to find base camp and
there's thousands like you'd go over
these Rolling Hills where we had to park
and there's no information and I'd come
over the hill and it'd be like 300
soldiers Japanese soldiers that I don't
speak English or they weren't speaking
English to me and I was trying to figure
out where I was dude it took me like two
hours to get to where I needed to go and
again it was so crazy that like at base
camp there was just no information so it
was a very weird experience like it was
really yeah it was crazy and then they
put me through like a boot camp with
like a real marine and you know we're
there with other actors and some actors
might look like Marines but they have
zero
you know they're just fumbling over
themselves I don't know how to hold a
gun or like you know when they're like
act like you're at War and crawl and
like you know there's a giant dude they
went to boot camp no we're in like a
temporary boot game it's just like uh
you know they like a like this is how
you do things quickly yeah or like to
make it look legitimate and then and and
they asked me if I want to do it and I
was like heck yeah and thank God I I can
not I can look like you know I can act
like I'm a soldier because this guy
would ream other actors like I mean he
was just Relentless like real and you no
not me he did I never gotten that
Crosshair thank God but like I mean I
saw like a giant man almost cry really
oh yeah an answer you know no I mean an
actor I met you know but
yeah it was uh it was intense it was it
was it was a it was a wild experience
and then all this stuff like day one
that we shot one scene well wait a
minute you're missing when you worked
with Clint the first time you met Clint
yeah I mean that was one of my first
scenes again like nice to see you
um
I mean he was super nice uh he had a lot
going on he did I mean he had so one of
my favorite Story the first time I
actually met him was again I didn't know
where base camp was because this thing
was massive right so we're we're talking
with like handlers I guess like and like
this marine guy like telling us what to
do and just it was such a simple scene
my first scene we were just running over
Hill I had no lines nothing just running
over Hill uh trying to escape for
whatever I don't even remember but so I
run over this hill and then there's this
whole thing behind me where uh bombs are
going off and like they you a couple
Marines capture a soldier or whatever
but so I'm one of the first over the
hill and come over this hill and space
game like oh here it is and clenise was
there and right next to base camp is
like
it looks like wood that has been in the
sea for I mean it's a desert so it's
just been just crazy pile of wood and
he's poking a stick at it and I'm like
you know I went up to introduce myself
and he like without didn't he looked at
me but then he was like
this thing is crazy and I was like I
didn't know what he was talking about
he's poking the wood and I thought he
was like I was like with wood and then
finally this crazy looking squirrel
comes running out and that was what he
was doing and that's how I met him at
first crazy it's a crazy crazy and I was
just dying laughing and I was like this
is the first time I met him he's gonna
win Awards with I bet and the first time
I met him he's like not paying attention
to what's going on at all now granted
every time after that he was and you
know the next time I ran over but it was
just funny the first time I met him it
didn't even look like he was watching
what was going on he was paying
attention to the squirrel I think
there's something to that I think
there's more than just a old guy kind of
poking at a squirrel maybe I think you
know these guys who are so confident
with themselves
can actually stop thinking about things
for just a minute yeah five plus like I
said it was a the scene wasn't important
that well regardless but I think he can
just like do that like just like have a
conversation with somebody and not worry
about it it's gonna happen you know what
I mean I just that's what I gather from
him it was just like if it's funny last
night I watched The Unforgiven have you
ever seen or just Unforgiven Ryan you've
never seen Unforgiven I haven't seen
Unforgiven though
it is one of the best movies Best
Western I've ever seen and I've seen a
lot it is incredible the acting Gene
Hackman Clint Eastwood Morgan Freeman
it's freaking powerful Richard Harris
you gotta watch that dude you gotta
watch that but yeah you worked I mean
working with him I mean I just that had
to be so exciting for you it was cool to
check off The Bucket List Steph for sure
I wish I would have been able to do more
yeah we always wished just like I had a
seven minute scene in a movie and I was
just like oh my God this is yeah you
know in fact you know my uncle's like
well it's still the best work you've
done I was like 26 or something I was
like well thanks um but look you've done
a lot of stuff uh did you ever think
that you know you were going to be
famous I mean did you ever did you did
you look a lot of actors say
no no I never thought about that I just
wanted to be an actor and it's [__]
I wanted to yeah Amos I want to but like
when you were on Smallville were you
starting to work you were like what were
you thinking I know you said you this is
what I want to do yeah I I definitely uh
yes there's a part of me that you know
like enjoys
being famous in the sense of being
successful because being successful
means I'm doing something right right
um so I mean yes I I mean from again
from Smallville days is like really when
I put it in my head of like
um this is what I want to do and I want
to be successful and you know obviously
Fame comes with that and and still to
this day I'm still chasing I still would
I would love to be more successful than
I'm happy where what I've done with but
trust me every actor wants wants more we
want uh I'm gonna to be able to get to
the point in your career where you
choose the narrative or you get to
choose your projects or you're writing
your own stuff and it's getting greenlit
instantly that would be fantastic do you
think you want to have a family for sure
you do so your parents set this this bar
like hey this is this is great family is
great yes and it's something that you
like hey this works and I know it works
and I want to have that yes so you want
to have a lot of kids like you want to
adopt kids like they did I would love to
again
listen I had a plan in my head that you
know I'm 36 now so things kind of
haven't you know I always thought I'd be
married like when I was younger growing
up in the midwest I'd be married with a
kid a white picket by 30. for sure yeah
um living in La is definitely different
you know it's it's a tough dating scene
it's a tough everything I mean just
living out here is rough
um so
I would I definitely want to adopt I
don't think I'll have I won't have 15.
but I would like to have a couple 14.
two three four fourteen you said you're
14 siblings 14 siblings yeah so you and
14. so it'd be 15. see Ryan I know I was
wrong I was still confused I was still
there's a lot of us you know if you can
throw any number it doesn't matter
um do you get Starstruck I mean no you
work with not at all no nobody Sigourney
Weaver no
that that's the one blessing for I I've
just been in around entertainment so
much I mean trust me there's people I'm
like oh that's really cool like it's
more Sports FaZe you no because again
once you get to meet them like uh
they're they're just normal people I
mean as you know like it's you're around
the glitz and Glam so like you go to war
shows or whatever like there really are
just normal people
um
now you respect their work so that's the
thing like for me I love sports so like
if like I met Michael Jordan or I have
met Michael Jordan when I was younger
but I mean if I met him again it'd be
more of like a you're badass but like I
don't need to I don't Fran growing out
or and I understand it but it's just
something that it's just something you
never really gave a [__] about yeah I
mean I want to meet trust me like
there's people I want yeah you want to
work with I respect them but in terms of
like the star aspect it's just like a
yeah I'm around it in LA all 24 7. you
know I mean now do you drink uh yes I'm
Irish you're Irish I guess there you go
um did you fall into the party scene at
all did you get involved in all the
drugs and all the [__] and like going
what am I doing and then get out of that
quickly so thank again because my
parents uh I was in and around that in
Hollywood
um so not going to college not you know
being that young like I mean I moved out
here when I was right before I was 18.
um so my college experience was growing
like getting a house with other actors
uh you know like a four bedroom house
and four actors that are 18 19 living in
a house and you know it was crazy and
you know you have some bad eggs that are
not uh we'll call them bad eggs but eggs
that are not uh uh good influence or the
people they bring around you know just
being in Hollywood so I definitely got
into trouble
um the thing about me is I'm very lucky
I think genetics I don't have an
addictive personality so I never got
caught up into anything and I've seen
friends you know fall apart oh the worst
um so in that aspect I always worked
really hard and then I played hard
um and I'm not an alcoholic in my life
when I was younger especially I was a
problem Drinker you know like there's no
like one drink for me it's like one if
I'm having one I'm out all night in my
20s now it's too old I can't do that
anymore and
um but yeah I definitely so you've done
it yeah you've done it all your parents
ever have a talk with you like what are
you doing why are you dealing with
what's going on they still have it talk
you know like they still know they still
worry about me I live in Los Angeles
they know
um and thankfully again you know like
it's they don't have anything to worry
about right now but she never got
arrested or anything no I'd be
interested you have been arrested I was
never you know when I was
hey there folks it's Michael Rosenbaum
and boy have I got a huge announcement
for you this has been a long time coming
and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're going to
make it a lot of fun we're planning a q
a maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there
I was in college but I wasn't 21 I went
to back home to Indiana we went to this
place kipley's and I snuck in with a
fake ID
and I was sitting at a booth and one of
my friends comes over and goes hey the
ABC's here and ABC is like yeah yeah the
alcohol like the police that are
checking for alcohol I don't know what
does it stand for I should know this I
don't remember anymore alcohol
Boys Club I don't know so um I ran out
the back door and hidden these bushes
across the uh parking lot near this
house
and I just stayed there for about 30
minutes down and then I finally go
nobody's chasing you they're gone
and I got up I started to walk out
lights came on got cop comes out with a
gun goes get get out get up now get up
put your hands up put your hands up I go
oh I don't have anything he's like you
know and he comes over and my wallet and
he get everything out of your pockets I
and I dumped it and a condom was on the
floor he's like he said something about
I don't remember like oh yeah you're
gonna use that huh something in uh his
name I'll never forget because you could
ask anybody where I grew up
Ronald McDonald
he was a tough cop in Evansville you
didn't want to mess with him he was
there's no forgiveness from this guy
this guy wasn't gonna go hey have a good
night you're speeding a little bit slow
down son never heard of that no you're
getting written up and you're you know
he'll do whatever it takes to make your
life hell
I was born in a small town
uh and they gave me minor entering a
Tavern under age resisting arrest
uh minor consumption and what's funny is
he let me go let me go for the night to
like leave he didn't arrest me
but then
the other cop as I'm walking in my car
goes hey buddy come here
he looks at me goes what are you doing I
go I'm gonna drive home because
you get in that car he's gonna he's
gonna give you a DUI he's waiting for
you to get in the car
don't get in the car
and I go okay and I just stood outside
my car door for like two hours
even after he drove off I waited 30 more
minutes and then I drove
it's home late I never forget my dad
when he goes he made me wear a suit to
court
he was like I was sitting in the
passenger seat and he was just like he
was such a dick
he goes you know embarrassing that this
is I'm taking my son to court with all
these other lowlifes
you know and we go there he's just like
and I just it was just awful I hated it
it was but that was that's a good parent
I think you know it's tough but well he
could have been like hey you know well
yeah I mean there's different types of
parenting but for me I don't but nothing
was
I'm not look I I was an [__] you know
yeah I made a mistake but you know
things like that like he didn't have any
yeah I go hey what would you do if uh
got my ear pierced because you'd go on a
halfway house you wouldn't be here like
okay Meanwhile my ear is bleeding
because Candy Shepherd next door just
pierced my ear and I'm looking in with
my writing I go oh cool I'll be at nades
for the next week
Jesus that's I don't have tattoos for
like my parents same thing you don't
have tattoos no they my parents would
murder me
really I still I mean I I I'm not scared
but it's like a respect thing I bet you
don't say F in front of your no I don't
I do you say f-bombs I try not to now I
mean now but when I was in my like 20s I
was like a same sort of thing like once
I was able to drink or I was a little
punk where I was like I can do because
my parents were strict and then I had
that thing where I just was rebelling
against them or whatever and my parents
were still always cool with me and um so
it was just like this dumb thing that I
had in my head where but I still I still
had
I wanted their respect I still want
their respect more than anything
um which is why like you know I I
actually really like tattoos I'm a lot
of friends that are covered in tattoos I
don't want to deal with it as an actor
because you know you're in the makeup
even longer but now it isn't so easy you
could I think about it sometimes but
then I also think my mom would kill me
so it's just not worth it did your mom
know when you got arrested your parents
know no they never knew they did
eventually but I tried to you know Ryan
oh they're super disappointed I mean
it's you know it's the same sort of
thing what your dad said let's just
drinks it's not wrong all that [__] you
know so yeah
um did you know Teen Wolf was going to
be that big of a hit
uh well so I jumped on the third season
oh so it was already hit so it already
was a a giant hit my my story is kind of
crazy though I knew about Teen Wolf
before it ever started because I worked
with
um one of the directors who's also a
producer on the show on prayers for
Bobby he directed prayers for Bobby
Russell
um and so I auditioned for season one of
Teen Wolf
um and then I auditioned for season two
where
um
for a different role where I was it was
between me and another kid or a couple
kids but I mean I auditioned for that
one like 17 times I had Teen Wolf 17
times a ton in front of for just for MTV
and MTV wasn't behind me and they had an
offer out to Daniel Sharman
um who had just come off like a really
popular movie at the time the Immortals
I think
um and I didn't know that so they just
like it felt like they kept giving me
different notes like they're like oh
he's too edgy he needs to be more GQ or
he's got to be more nerd so like I'd go
in these auditions like dressed
completely different every time and
they'd be like and it was just smoke and
mirrors they're waiting for Daniel to
answer them and MTV didn't like me
um so yeah the third season is when I
actually got on did they offer it to you
or you have to audition uh that one was
uh no I auditioned but it was I was
heavily favored really yeah finally this
guy's paid his dues yes like I always
had people on Teen Wolf behind me now
and and Russell for sure that's good
yeah yeah you have to have cheerleaders
you have to have somebody out there
that's rooting for and that's so
important in life it's like having some
somebody that believes in you yeah
because I owe them a lot it's hard to
believe in yourself sometimes when
nobody else does so if you have that one
person I always talk about that you know
my you know I had a teacher that
actually was patient with me I remember
Mr Morrow Mr Morrow in fact I went back
home in Indiana and uh I said hey we're
all going to taroni's for some pizza I'm
taking Everybody's Pizza why don't you
come yes
I'd love that
I would love to do that so old Mr Morrow
straight up and all my friends were like
what who's this I go this is Mr Morrow
some did but like yeah yeah he was like
he was a substitute teacher thank God
for this in this one year and uh we hit
it off he was just he was just cool
buddy you know he was he didn't try
anything like I was stupid yeah exactly
and it means the world when you're a kid
you know like just someone to
that you connect with or that you know
doesn't treat you like a child yeah it
means a lot when you're a kid so you get
the role and I know MTV and a lot of
these streamers I I I I assume to be is
probably pretty cheap
um but MTV money I remember I did a show
and I mean guys I'm telling you I got
this pilot for MTV with Jackson browne's
son Ethan great guy and Leslie Bibb
and the three of us did this show
and I was paid four thousand dollars for
the pilot
sounds about right and after taxes and
everything was about for three four
weeks I I think I had fourteen hundred
dollars yeah
and then yeah so I know and then they
wanted me to do a development deal
because uh the pilot didn't go but they
liked me we'll give you five grand I'm
like whoa yeah
that's what I thought but I mean
were you like was it the same same story
MTV does not they're not known for
paying well but did they start to pay
you in season four and season five I
mean or was it just never a thing about
money with that show they no they were
it was tough always battle even the
actors that were there from the
beginning were battling MTV's just not
see the cool thing though with MTV that
we got lucky with is
um like the CW for instance uh
conventions you know like the fans are
so strong and so powerful that doing
these conventions pays good money
um and so that's where the money comes
to get that keeps on giving yeah with
Teen Wolf we could do conventions with
Teen Wolf names whatever like we could
they uh like the arrow ones or like ones
for CW it's always like bow and arrow or
like something that's not nothing to do
with Teen Wolf but it's like similar you
know right whereas for whatever MTV
didn't have any of those restrictions on
us so you know we did well in
conventions if we were able to get away
from work how many cons did you do a
year on average again it depends on how
much you were working like so if you had
time to make it uh Sometimes some years
20 plus
um wow you know and then covert killed
it all I mean they're starting to come
back but uh but yeah they it I really
enjoy them it's a blast you get to
interact with fans in a short you know
like in in a short weekend you know get
to get to bounce ideas off them I had a
really fun experience of one of my uh
like my little Arc was figuring out what
my character was I was Supernatural but
you didn't know and Teen Wolf didn't let
me know either so I was kind of figuring
out as we go so I actually would love
going to these conventions and like
bouncing ideas off
um some people like amazing idea some
people yeah oh well same sort of thing
but there's some of their ideas I mean
they're smarter than me in every way you
know they come up with things like yeah
they know more I feel like an idiot
sometimes they're like well when you
have this this the key is I'm like I am
Tom and I like I have no clue they'll
come up with things in the script that
what what they've come up with makes
perfect sense where you're like I don't
think the writers were that smart maybe
I don't you know like the time of your
watch and you're like I don't think it I
mean that's amazing that you came up
with that but I don't maybe I gotta ask
that and then you go ask me like no we
didn't do it you know like they're so
smart and they pick up on everything so
for me I had a blast and then some of
their story and things that they would
come up with was fascinating and then it
and then I would be like kind of repeat
some of that and try to sound smart but
yeah well I think uh here's my idea
because I know well I'd be like no I
bounce these ideas off with bubble you
know yeah but uh but you know I I loved
it it was actually a lot of fun it was
one of the coolest things ever that that
because most most of the time you know
what everything about your character you
get a script you know everything and you
can't tell anyone and at first I hated
it because I was like this is so I want
to know like what if I'm playing it
wrong what if like I'm doing this this
and this and all of a sudden they tell
me I'm like this and that doesn't make
sense at all yeah so it bothered me for
a little bit but then I was like no I'm
just gonna have fun with this like the
writers aren't going to do me wrong like
they're gonna they'll let me know when
it you know and how I've been playing it
is kind of I assume how they're going to
write it so then I just when I just
started when I stopped caring about that
and had fun with it my most enjoyable
time was with fans bouncing ideas being
like dude I don't know like I think
because you know it was it was a it was
a lot of fun do you remember the first
time you went to a con and were you
Blown Away by how many people were there
to see you were you like is there gonna
be anybody there do they care again I
knew because Teen Wolf was already
established and and they've already seen
conventions like I knew what to expect
but I mean yes for your first time I
mean the craziest thing is especially
like overseas like Paris or Frank for
whatever reason like kids I don't know
what it is but there'll be like 500 kids
at two in the morning at your hotel out
front are you serious yeah that part's
that part's intense where you're just
like you know you can't sleep or the
airport you deal with a lot of the
airport sometimes they're pretty good at
trying I mean every once in a while
something gets leaked somehow or and
then you show up and there's somehow
like whoa how'd they figure that out
um so a lot of times it's it's normally
an actor doing something dumb like
posting you know like a ticket like look
what I'm flying it has to think of the
time so they're like but people do that
or like you know like first time act
like one thing that like I definitely
remember getting like the talk like all
right like one of my first conventions
uh like big ones uh they're like don't
post the hotel like don't even post a
picture because then they'll figure it
out or don't even post for across the
street because they the fans will figure
it out and sure enough like some someone
will accidentally slip something and
then next thing you know they figure out
where you are all because of they could
see like they're investigators well
that's the wallpaper from the uh and the
Hilton over in on Bird Street yeah
they'll figure it out they do figure it
out yeah that was that's weird I used to
I finally used an alias
um it's a kid who picked on me in high
school so I used his name no but um yeah
and it's funny because I go back to
Vancouver every once in a while to work
and the last time I went I was with my
brother and uh I walked into the lobby
of the Sutton Place and I'll make up a
name but the the head guy goes good
evening Mr Johnson or whatever and I go
and my brother goes
and my in the name is such a funny thing
because I used to always talk about this
guy picking on me when I was kids my
brother when he heard that he was like
Oh and it was some a name that's kind of
yeah that sounds funny yeah I won't say
it because obviously I don't have an
alias name that'd be stupid Ryan
I think I wouldn't be smart
um yeah cons are incredible there's one
thing I will say because I told Michelle
my friend Michelle
uh her and Chris they just they lost
their their boy Preston who was a good
buddy of mine he was 16 to a horrible
cancer and I you know he was Ronald you
know went to the Ronald McDonald house
and they helped him and he went through
I don't know how many surgeries I sat
with this kid through chemo visited in
the hospital I FaceTime with all my
superhero friends like Zach Levi and
Welling and all these guys and
great kid I used to drive up to Hemet to
see him and his family and we'd watched
in fact his favorite show was Teen Wolf
and if he knew I was talking to you
right now I wish he I wish he would go
crazy in fact his mom we were texting
and she's like oh my God and she said
it's hard for me to even watch that show
because and and when it ended Preston
was so upset he was so upset and
downstairs here
I go what's your favorite show
and he goes Teen Wolf and I go
Teen Wolf
really
I hadn't seen Teen Wolf and he goes yeah
can we watch it and I go
yeah let's watch Teen Wolf we ended up
watching like three episodes of the
first season and I was like this is fun
this is kind of fun and he knew that he
knew like some of the lines and but it's
amazing and what I felt like when I go
to these cons you know for Smallville or
anything I've done when when you could
see like hey this was a mo this was
something my dad and I had on Tuesday
nights or this is and it means so much
to people and you don't realize you're
like that's just a show how could this
mean something and so how does that make
you feel how do you how do you deal with
that stuff
uh
I mean you feel awesome especially like
I was I hope in my life I get to do more
but like you mentioned a film I did with
Sigourney called prayers for Bobby now
that movie is based on a true story
about a young boy Bobby Griffith who who
sadly kills himself
um because he's gay you know his family
doesn't accept him and you know like so
many families who are Uber religious and
think that that's wrong uh would just
chalk it up as you know the devil got a
hold of him or you know hopefully you
know well Mary Griffith did a 180 and
realize she's the one who killed her son
not you know not her you know she pushed
her son to death right uh and instead of
continuing that style she does complete
180 and you know to this day she was one
of the leading activists for uh lgbtq
plus rights wow I mean it's just the
story in itself is mind-boggling and
talking to her about her son and her
interactions and that stuff is also
you're like it
the amount of respect I have for to
openly talk about that you know be like
you're telling me you killed your son
and she's like you know it's the worst
the hardest thing I've ever done in my
life is to admit to admit that and
realize that I did that you know and
then she's like now from here on out I'm
trying to correct that it's a powerful
it's a powerful message so a movie like
that like trust me I would I would meet
people all the time and I still meet him
all the time who write me letters and
and be like you know you've changed the
way my parents talk to me or like you
meet like a giant must be military man
giant Burly man comes up to you and
you're like let's come up and shake my
hand and be like I look at my son
differently because of you and you're
like what it's it's once and again you
have that stuff same thing with Teen
Wolf stuff but for me with Teen Wolf you
know the same sort of thing we're like
it's just a TV show about werewolves but
it does affect people's lives or if
you're going through a bad time and you
know you're you're struggling to get out
of bed you find joy in a show that that
you know brings you laughter or you know
keeps you waking up the next day and
just to get you out of that funk you
know it means a lot to people and that
and that's the thing where you're like
wow this is bigger than just me acting
and uh and it's cool and that's the
stuff that really I enjoy that aspect I
love when people tell me things like
that and same sort of thing I've had
experiences where uh you know I met a
girl who who she's passed away since but
uh Teen Wolf was her favorite thing and
she was squirrels dying of cancer she
was young and she and again I was
terrified I had to go like in like a
hazmat suit to even talk with her uh I
went there with some of the casts and I
was terrified I was like I don't know if
I can handle this like I'm not good with
death I don't want to see a kid that's
you know that only has a week left to
live like what how am I supposed to be
strong for this child and then going in
there was like one of the most powerful
things I've ever experienced because she
was stronger than any one of us
you know that like she would crack jokes
about her dying with her parent and be
like well I'm not worried about me I'm
worried about my parents you know like
just Con in her her her energy was
insane and so to do things like that is
pretty cool yeah I would go
so the Ronald McDonald House a lot and I
would have to walk out and go to the
bathroom and get you know my composure
because I would just feel it coming and
I'd go in there and I would just like
break down for like five minutes and
then kind of get it together because it
was just I mean there's nothing worse
than a child something there just isn't
I I can't I can't imagine anything worse
than that you know it's like
you know sometimes it takes looking at
someone and going wow you're never gonna
have a life
you're never gonna
meet a girl and have a you know maybe a
a guy have a family and travel and and
just nothing I mean you're gonna
everything is so premature it's strange
financially that it puts on the parent
like every you see they're just barely
holding on it's tough It's it's and it's
everywhere I'm gonna cry right now I'm
thinking about it yeah it's terrible
seriously yeah I could too it's like
it's yeah I
yeah
it's not for the faint of heart that's
for sure
um
well that's awesome yeah no it is it's a
good thing I mean yeah we're lucky I
always say that we're lucky that we can
do things we make we can make money
doing things we love and and people you
know support them yeah
um do you uh even to this day now you're
36 years old or you got a girlfriend how
long uh a little over a year
yeah yeah you thinking maybe uh
you haven't gotten there no it's always
at my age it's always in your head you
know so it's so you know I'm not dating
to just date anymore you know so so yes
she's incredibly important to me and
timing is you know it's there's things
that she has going on in her life and
mine you know I'm a big believer and
there's no rush so even though a year a
year is like
still like yeah
this person's crazy after six months or
you know another thing that I'm hugely
you know like I think is incredibly
important it was like no no with my
family when I was younger uh living with
someone before they're married I think
it's like you have to you have to yes
you have to that's the next step my
friends are always worried that I know
you're gonna just meet someone and get
married no I'm not I'm gonna live with
them yeah and if they could live with me
and I could live with them yeah that's
yeah I've never had that can you believe
it I'm 50 I've never lived with a girl
well I live with this woman
for five months but we live with our
parents
that was kind of weird
how old are you
almost mid-20s yeah
I know people do that that was a long
time ago
now it would be weird if you did that
what if he moved into some girl's
parents house I think that uh yeah it's
50 year old man living with you know
that's such a crazy world dating do you
were you ever on the dating apps Gail
yeah you have to you have to I mean it's
as much as I hate that the whole concept
of listen if you're if you're out there
dating and you're like here's a perfect
example I went out when I was I went
through a heartbreak so I went out to up
out I was out mingling like I'm gonna
try and I saw this girl who I thought
was beautiful and I know again I have
nine sisters I just know I knew it was
girls night I know I'm gonna get shut
down by friends even if I could make it
to her but the thing I was like maybe
Ryan maybe you're just being just do it
just who cares come on what's the worst
that could happen so I go and trust me
her friends try to shut me down and I
get to her and she's friendly but want
nothing to do with me and I [__] you not
the next day you're not the next day but
like at least a couple days later she
matched I saw her on a dating app and I
was like no way and so I you know didn't
expect anything of it anyway so she
matched and I joked around with her and
I was like hey you know like just so you
know I mentioned the other and she's
like what and you turned me down yeah
and she was like oh that was girls night
I don't even remember you know like it's
it's girls already talking no no this is
years ago that would have been a really
nice story but it's that that thing
where girls are already talking to guys
on dating apps already so if you meet
them out in person you're already behind
the curve you know and like how do you
like you never go to the thing that I
miss is I just got to experience this
when I was younger going to a bar
and and if your friends didn't show up
you stayed there and mingled with other
people and you met other friends now
I'll never go to a bar that my friends
are at because they text you immediately
you know they're like a change of plans
we're going to rock and Riley's or
change of plans where you know so you'd
never you never do that thing we're like
where's I don't know call him and you
leave like so the concept of like
different people Pockets don't mix as
much it's so it's not as organic yeah
it's like and even when you get on those
dating apps I don't know how many times
I'm like oh she seems scared
career she's uh you know she's pretty I
collect oh I matched with it this is
great no you know should I wait a day I
don't want to be desperate here and then
I'll say
something funny you know hey uh crickets
yeah and then
either crickets and five days go by and
I go hey just uh saying hey one more
time hope you're well
nothing I delete it delete her what was
that or sometimes they'll say hey what's
up and I go hey how are you there you
know and a few things and then they're
gone
or it's just so and I don't wanna
um meet someone
on a dating app and then they're like
all right let's get dinner now it's
three hours with somebody I haven't met
you yet so I would like to FaceTime you
let's see if we have a rapport or meet
for lunch okay
you know lunch is an hour yeah nobody
has a longer than an hour long coffee
and that's it man and and 90 of those
don't end up going past coffee no or
lunch well I mean and I always feel bad
it's like you know I have a good time
and I I inadvertently sometimes you know
I don't say like I like you or I just
say oh great I'm interested and because
I want to be interested in someone and
then I go and
they're like hey how are you what's
going on well it's just the worst you
mean also I swear I've met girls where
their roommate texts for them because
they're hilarious they're sharp they're
witty and then and then you go get
coffee with them and you're like hmm
what happened to what where's the jokes
where's the sarcasm yeah
you know but it's not and they're just
it's so it's just dating apps are the
worst in it 99 of them never even make
it to coffee because they just ghost you
or they disappear or they're talking to
someone else or again also like I also
have an ego too so like if someone
doesn't respond to me too long I'm like
well [__] you you know like and then
which maybe they're busy like maybe they
actually have something going on my
mind's always saying yeah I'm like well
[__] like I'm important too yeah you get
you feel like kind of like insulted yeah
you know what what's wrong with me yeah
what do I do what I say or if a girl
cancels for whatever reason like again
it could be a perfect example I've
canceled in my life like things happen
but in my head I'm like nope I'm worth
I'm valuable you know and you're like
and that could be a perfect potential
person
your fault yeah that's your problem
that's my problem but as I get older
it's harder and harder you know like
getting when I was younger I was way
more conducive towards putting up with
and molding around someone's issues now
I'm like no red flag red flag red flag
see that's but the older you get the
longer you wait for someone the more
right the red flags that were just like
like I don't know what's uh what's a
very light I didn't have red flags in my
20s but I'm colorblind what's a light
red that you can't really make it's not
strong red maybe it's gonna be a pink
the whitish pink maybe like a uh like a
Vermillion okay call it a Vermillion
it's just like you know all these all
these flags are everywhere and it's like
you gotta just think about
what can I deal with and my friend once
said listen
you have a great life single life you do
a lot of yep great friends you have a
lot of fun going obviously I want to be
in a
burp in a relationship and you know have
somebody to travel with and be there for
me and stuff and
um but he's like I just want you to know
coming from someone who has 23 years
with someone my friend Tom he goes
just know this
when you're in a relationship with
someone
their problems
your problems
so you have your problems but you also
have their problems
and I was like oh [__] I don't even have
time to deal with my problems yeah yeah
I don't even know how to deal with my
problems now I gotta deal with their
problems but it's true you have to sort
of yeah it's a give and take yeah and
again I swear to God I mean I'm
experienced it but dating in La is the
hardest in the world there is no it's
the worse it is it's and people are my
friends in Indiana Oh yeah you're
welcome come in I'm like yeah I went out
with Nicole Kidman yeah she's I have her
number it's you should totally date her
I'm like what are you talking about but
it's like they don't they don't realize
you know but in Indiana the converse is
everybody's married everybody has kids
that's what you do there's no single
people over 20 in Indiana that's just
everyone's career driven here they've
got their goals and and the first sign
of a speed bump they're already swiping
on the next person you know like that's
true
how do you deal with uh mental health
how do you deal with like uh being
motivated being um not being anxious
being down on yourself being uh do you
deal with be ever depression at all yeah
I mean I thankfully I've been blessed I
don't I I don't want to call it real
depression you know because some people
struggle with some stuff that I could
never understand
um but I definitely get I mean human
nature to get down on yourself
um for me I get in low periods of my
life when I don't have purpose so
something I struggle with my 20s a lot
you know
what yeah acting is I did a movie with
Armin Bueller Stahl
um went called uh my brain's not working
right now um
oh I should know this uh
dust Factory there we go it came to me
uh and when I was a kid he told me you
know to be a successful actor you need
Hobbies I didn't know what the heck he
was talking about in my head he was a
painter a musician he did everything
um and I was just like as a kid I was
like that made no sense and it wasn't
until like my 30s where I was like oh
and my 20s I go crazy like when I'm
working I'm happy as a clam you know I'm
so everything's awesome and it's those
down times right that's when I get into
trouble or if I you know like I don't
have things to do or you start you know
like you get lonely or whatever so so
having purpose keeping myself busy you
know like even just going to the gym in
the morning helps me keep my mind moving
for for a reason it's those times where
like you know like say if you just did
you just got off a series or a film you
know and you have like two months off
it's it's easy to just be like I'm just
gonna relax and for those two months I
would my it would mess with me mentally
oh yeah rather than you know you'd think
like oh yeah I'm I'm that's good for my
health I'm taking a break no I need to
have things to do to to make it so like
you know because the average person they
have a nine to five and you know they
just they just keep going through it for
me I'm meant for that not nine to five
but like staying busy because when I
have down time that's when I get into
trouble that's when I do stupid things
that's when I I just do dumb things when
I have too much free time and I get down
on myself the most dangerous word in the
dictionary sedentary
that's what when I'm just not doing
anything just sitting there
I think everything's fine I could watch
a movie and then the movie's over and
then I'm thinking
what am I doing I put on another movie
and I'm thinking and I'll go upstairs
I'm thinking yeah it's it's like you
know some people need to be busy I think
everyone needs to have a little actions
yeah and you know I said it millions of
times but you don't have to
you know be a a movie star You Don't
Have To Be A Millionaire to be happy or
have Passions
everyone loves something everyone loves
doing something
besides watching TV and like you know
going out for a hike or you know going
to play softball with friends or
learning guitar or whatever it is
Hobbies Hobbies like he said it's so
it's so true like I have that's the
thing I have a lot of hobbies you know a
lot and that's thank God for those thank
God for still playing some sports and
still playing guitar and music and all
this stuff
because those lulls can get and get you
yeah especially when you're young and
you're you're always like you're always
working and going to this and hey we're
going to this party and hey we're going
here hey you're going to Toronto you're
gonna shoot this and you're gonna and
then all of a sudden everything stops
and you're like who am I what the f what
am I doing here
and it's just it's scary all right this
is called [__] talking with Ryan Kelly
these are my top tiers rapid fire
perfect this is uh go to uh inside of
you uh patreon.com inside of you Patron
save the show they really uh support the
show and if you want to become a patron
do it it's a lot of fun all right Miss
Kayla Sue what was the biggest blessing
and biggest challenge of being one in 15
kids the biggest blessing and the
biggest challenge biggest blessing is I
can handle any personality that ever
exists you know like I'm such a people
person you can't good there's not a
person out there that like you know like
I might not like I can make I'm such a
people person you can put me in a room
and I'm I can I can make it happen I
might not enjoy them as much as but like
I'm not the type of person who gets
freaks out like you know I can handle
anyone uh challenge
uh knowing their birthdays yeah right
um the biggest challenge I mean I'm just
trying to think like I never knew
anything different getting lost in the
mix maybe but I never felt like I was
lost we were that's a really good
question I don't I've never had it
worded like that so where I'm like what
was it I mean I just uh
traveling well yeah but again I didn't
know he didn't we didn't travel so like
those things sounds what about favorites
jealousy probably I'm sure you know I
was my mom's favorite you are well I
traveled with my mom were you the
youngest no a middle but no but I but my
siblings always make fun of me saying I
was my mom's favorite and it's just
because I spent the most time with her
because of acting because I needed a
guardian so my mom and I got really
close so I'm for sure a mama's boy they
put all that money in a trust fund or
whatever for you or did you have to give
some to them oh I definitely had to I
mean it wasn't that to the family you
know like coming on to Los Angeles you
know the Oakwood apartments with that
was expensive renting a car for three
months out of the year to make it there
for pilot season that that stuff was
that money was never mind I never
thought of it it was my family it was a
thing that they helped me get to where I
am today so I got some money but some of
it was gone you know put towards things
that my family right perfect sense
um all right Michelle K as a Chicago
native deep dish or regular pizza tape
dish all day I love deep dish yeah I
mean I've seen I mean even bad pizza
I'll eat I love pizza pizza but Ryan
there's a good deep dish place out here
there's
uh it's on Melrose say it oh [__] I
don't remember its name it's not all
right there used to be take Chicago I
mean that was terrible remember that
spot in Burbank it was from uh that act
um I should know this I don't like the
pizza here either it's terrible I mean
it's not you know again I can eat shitty
pizzas so I'll still my buddy owns
Prince Street Pizza and he says it's
great uh my friend Larry Lawrence oh
they got the pepperoni cups those things
there yeah isn't what they do is that
their thing I don't haven't been but I'm
I gotta check it out press Pizza print
Street pizzas listen again bad Pizza is
still good to me you haven't tried no I
haven't all right
Leilani and when you were on Smallville
did you have any techniques or tricks
that help you act out those emotional
scenes with Clark
what are you thinking about
uh I always think of it it changes every
time I have to cry but I think of like a
terrible situation so like
um
like yeah picture something awful like
your mom gets hit by me this is gonna be
terrible but your mom gets hit by a car
she's pinned between a car and you're
the only like I'm the only sibling that
gets arrives at the scene and the cops
like hey she's coherent but you have two
minutes to talk to your mom before she's
gone and then you're just whiffed away
and like what you can do that what I
would say to my mom and then just
thinking like that you know just like
and then I can't use that again because
it doesn't work because I use that so I
have to think of other and then
sometimes it takes me a little bit to
figure out what that one is and once I
find it then I'm like honing on that and
I can do that but it's weird every time
it's something completely different and
then the thing that worked me for the
last time doesn't trigger this thing
because I'm like I did that right I I
hear you Jessica B tell us how you felt
when they announced they were doing the
Teen Wolf movie
shocks I couldn't I was like what you
know we went from doing this if anything
I expected another season and then when
that didn't happen you know it was kind
of just like it was a question yeah and
it was awesome and yes we want a little
bit more but at the same time sometimes
you know riding off with wanting more is
always better than you know to where
something is just bad and yeah like just
beating a dead horse so I wasn't I was
content so when the films was like what
that's cool well you already said this
so you don't have to answer but Ruby M
we answered this in the interview just
saw prayers for Bobby what a great movie
what has the impact on you after you
worked on Paris Revival but you already
told me so there you yeah I just wanted
to say your name Ruby uh jam and Jenny
you've been performing since you're a
kid do you have any particular mentors
along your way which ones who everyone I
work with I mean even like even working
with you guys I told you you guys truly
impacted my life so when you when I got
the email from me I was like what this
is this is crazy because you guys
changed my life into where I was like I
specifically remember
and and you guys are also all very nice
so that was another thing like if you
guys were [__] which I've been on
sets where people are I probably would
have maybe gone a different route but
because you guys were so friendly
um and then on top of that it's I I seem
to see the joy that you guys had I was
like I want to be like
I like it
um you work with Shatner
uh I did Boston Legal short I I not as
much he was like I never got to directly
work with him he was in a scene no he
wasn't in anyone he was around but no I
didn't get you ever talk to him uh I had
a conversation with them for like 30
minutes and he was super it was okay it
was about my family and he was just
making fun of me 15 kids yeah he was how
did you do that yeah that was exactly
what were you were you um uh
upset a lot of the time because a lot of
kids yeah I've talked to them too and
the next time I see him he's like I
don't know I don't know you yeah what is
this uh this has been a real treat it's
been a real treat seeing you grow up to
be such a great guy
and I know you're gonna get married some
sometime you're gonna have kids I love
that you had a good family I love that
uh it seems so chaotic but it really
just worked for you yeah which it's so
important to to love your kids you know
and if you show them that and you pay
attention to them and you you're there
for them it's important it makes
their transition transition into
adulthood easier yes um when you don't
have that sort of um what's the uh
support yeah it's building blocks you
know like yeah yeah that's cool biggest
audition
that you almost got
that you didn't get biggest moving
oh uh
I don't know if I almost got it but I've
gotten far on stuff that like I got way
too excited like again something that
crushed me is the the Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man you know I had a couple
auditions for that and that was like my
childhood dream like being Spider-Man so
I don't think I was anywhere near how
many auditions four
you were near yeah so you were near but
um
yeah that was that would have been cool
oh man that was that one was where I
traveled I tried it was terrible no he
wasn't he was I tried to not not get
upset at that one but that one you know
I I cried in my pillow that night for
three years I still do actually still
cry
I still think about it yeah all right
dude thanks for coming out thanks for
having me good seeing you good seeing
you
nice guy yeah really just um it was easy
it was easy I like when it's easy
although sometimes when it's hard it's
like kind of forces you to kind of
being a little malleable a little
maneuverable a little
um so uh but I really enjoyed that I
really enjoyed Ryan it was fun
um all the stuff we said in the intro if
you didn't listen to it uh it's all
there so you could listen to it there
follow the podcast at inside you podcast
and on Instagram and Facebook and
saidypon and Twitter and I'm on Cameo
and uh patreon.com inside if you want to
get back to the the podcast and I'll
send you a message after if you want to
join and give back uh what else
um inside you online store all that
stuff Tom and I will be on the road
um where are we going we're going to uh
uh freaking DC and Rhode Island and
Nashville and uh you know the list goes
on so get tickets to come see us at a
con you can go to my Instagram uh at the
Michael Rosenbaum and it's on the link
tree and all the things we're doing
including Cami and all that stuff so you
could uh come visit us and we could hug
it out
um right now
I think it's time for the top tier shout
outs I think so you think so right I
agree we should do this probably all
right we're gonna do this this is the
top tier uh patrons um if you want to
become a member I'll send you a message
back but you get your name shouted out
if you join the top tiers and lots of
other perks and we're adding perks as we
speak
so thank you for being a patron if
you're a patron I love you I love you
thank you top tier patrons here they are
and they've been here for a while Nancy
D Leah and Kristen little Lisa Yukiko
Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason w
Dreamweaver
I mean a lot of these names have been
here just for so long
and it baffles me because I have
abandonment issues and I always assume
that one day I'm going to look on here
and no one's going to be here and I know
people have families and lives and but
uh it's just uh it's just awesome and it
means so much to me
so thank you uh Nico P Brian H I said
Sophie M Rashid Joshua D Jennifer and
Stacy L Jamal F Janelle b l Don Supremo
99 more San Diego M Chad W Leanne P
Maddie s Belinda and Dave Dave I miss
you Dave ho
Sheila G Brad d Ray H Tabitha T Tom and
by the way I'm having a top tier Zoom
coming up so check the patreon page
Talia M Tom and Betsy D Angel and
Rhiannon C Corey K wanna read a couple
yeah let's do it who's next
Dev Nixon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D
Joey M Eugene and Leah Corey Angela F
Mel s Christine s Eric H sh Shane R
Andrew M Amanda R and Jen B Kevin e
Stephanie K Jor l
jam and Jay Leanne J Luna R Mike F
Stonehenge Stone Age stay wild Moon
child Brian L Kendall ale Cara C Jessica
B Kyle F Marisol P Kaylee J Brian a
Ashley F Marion Louise L
Romeo the band Veronica Q Frank B gen T
Nikki L April R Derek n
jdw
calm bomb Rosen bomb Ginger
insomniac
Rachel D and Lorelei l
I just scratched my nose I didn't pick
it now I picked it okay great uh you
guys are awesome uh can do without you I
hope you enjoyed the podcast today and
keep listening spread the word and um
don't forget
October 11th
Wednesday
Regent Theater 7 P.M inside of you live
podcast with Zach Levi get your tickets
Ticketmaster on my Instagram
linktree get tickets come see me it's
gonna be a packed house I hope right now
we're doing pretty well we'll see Ryan
will be there so we'll see you soon from
Michael Rosemount I'm here in the
Hollywood Hills of California uh I'm
Ryan Tales here in Hollywood Hills
California as well Little Wave do we
like our new our new camera wide shot
camera angle uh I dig it I think it's
intimate yeah all right um thank you so
much for being here be good to yourself
I'll see you next week
foreign